EKAL SEX
MAXWELL, TANION D ALGEACJE
UNDERAGRS.GE DAY DEFENSS FORMER
HEAR NOTHINOTHIN
NASHE ECUTORS SO
GREEE MA
THAT WAS ROVROM JEFFREY
N'PA VILLAG ADULT ITEMS.
D JOINING ME NOWS THERF GHISLAI.
VERY DISCREET ABOUT ALL THISO
WHAT CAN YOUUS?
ELIMSTIFIED
ABOUT AN THU
IT ERG.NLT ON FORPAGES ANAN
D E HOW VIAFFRONTED HEASO  BEEN
OK LK THAT IT'S POSSIBLE THAT TT
HO WASINED BY MAXWELL'TEAM, Y D
POINTING OUT THAT WH HE HAID IKT
HEY FROMN  WAS NOTRUIN PREVIOU C
AND THAT I COUS
HE.
EEMED TO BE
OREF SIK HIS
HE LME
ROLLERS WHEWN EPSTEI
LUDING PNCEW, FORM P
INTON,R PRESIDENT TRUMP,
PAIR OF FORMER
CIRCUMSTANCET NG TO
YOUREPORTING, PEOPLE IN HIGH Y N
FALLOUT OF THIS TR>> S
POSSIBLY F BN THIS
WE'VE ALREAD NAMES
OF POWERFUL MEATIN
DIDN'T KNOY .L CARO BEINGTHK POL
TH PEO
S  TO  HIMSELFTHAT, IN
PARTU KNOWE
XW
FR
EYINHEEN LM  SE
E TOLD MATE STED SOSWE.
EPSTN'E UPLEL ALICTIM
MANIPULATION, DOOU
WHATYOATAND DO YOU ET
PLA TT  IT'S COLIIM
WEFRHIM ON HOW OCL WLDSKED TO BS
GGTE
HOUSE MANAGER
D EPSTN ATTEMPT
WAS AND THAT MAXWELL WAS
MANILANG TR THAT WF THOS
I N'N THE NECESSARILLA FACT